les délégués qui étaient réunis à paris
pour la conférence sur le climat ont dit
pendant deux semaines pratiqué lors très
difficile de concilier les contraires
entre les déclarations passionnées les
chefs d'état et le long travail de
négociation il a fallu trouver
l'équilibré entre le développement
économique et le respect de
l'environnement
entre les intérêts des petits pays qui
ne polluent pas mais qui subissent de
plein fouet les changements climatiques
et l'impunité et gros pollueurs se sont
opposés aussi l'activisme des petites
organisations et l'immobilisme des
géants nationaux
au final c'est vrai c'est un accord
historique qui a été conclu ça va faire
une grande différence pour mes enfants
pour des enfants canadiens
mais au delà des cibles et des milliards
on a surtout reconnu que si les pays ne
sont pas tous égaux devant les
changements climatiques
il n'y a qu'une seule façon d'y faire
face seule chose qui compte maintenant
c'est d'avoir raison ensemble ce sera
maintenant au pays participantes dont le
canada de transformer tous ses
engagements réalité